The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES SWAN: OK, shall we begin?
So on the syllabus,
today's class
is supposed to be a
review for the next quiz.
And I'm happy to answer
any questions you
have about the material
or about the quiz
to the best of my ability.
And when we've exhausted
those questions,
I have some notes on
another method for solving
partial differential equations.
We didn't really
cover it in class,
but I think it's quite
interesting and applicable
for chemical engineers
in particular
because of the classes of
problems that we study.
And then notes on how to
construct a simulation of a PDE
that follow from what
Professor Green discussed
during your last PDE lecture.
And we'll do an example
where we actually
develop a code to solve
the PDE and maybe refine it
so that it runs more
quickly by noticing
certain things about the
structure of the problem.
OK?
I have your gift cards.
I remembered them.
So I'll hand those out at the
end the class, just in case
more people trickle in.
But it doesn't look like
there's 53 people here,
so maybe the TAs are going to
be eating burritos for a while.
There's going to
be a lot left over.
We'll see.
I'll hold onto them.
Try to make sure everyone
gets their reward
for responding to
the class survey.
So let's start with questions
about the quiz, about
the material that we've
covered up to this point.
I'm really going to leave it
to you to point out things
that you feel like
you need help with,
you think need to be reviewed.
I know you've had a review
session with the TAs already.
Maybe that's been sufficient.
OK?
Questions.
It's up to you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Will the test contain
chemical engineering material
like last year's
test, or will it
be like Professor Green's test.
JAMES SWAN: Oh, good question.
So I'll tell you that
I believe the problems
on the quiz this
year are motivated
by chemical engineering
problems, OK?
The reason for that is,
unlike linear algebra problems
or optimization
problems, those can
be crafted out of whole cloth.
But workable, right,
boundary value problems,
workable initial
value problems really
need to stem from
something physical.
You are not asked
to derive anything
from your extensive chemical
engineering knowledge.
This is not a qualifier
for reactors or thermo
or transport.
We provide you
with those details.
OK?
But they are-- I think they
are of a chemical engineering
origin.
So you have equations that
are reasonable to work with.
OK?
More questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I would
love to briefly go
over some boundary value
problems, specifically
like the collocation and--
JAMES SWAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: --Galerkin
methods, maybe.
JAMES SWAN: Sure.
So OK.
So let's just discuss
boundary value problems first.
Turns out PDEs are a class of
boundary value problem, too,
largely, at least the ones
that chemical engineers
are interested in.
So if we understand boundary
value problems in general,
we should understand how to
solve partial differential
equations too.
Many classes of partial
differential equations
that we're interested in can
also be solved in these ways.
So we talked about
relaxation methods
in general, which were
these methods that
rely on somehow discretizing the
continuous function that we're
trying to describe in this
boundary value problem.
So usually, you've got some--
linear function,
some linear operator
that operates on some variable
that we're trying to understand
in a boundary value problem.
Maybe it's temperature,
right, equals 0.
So it's going to be something
like thermal diffusion.
This equation could
represent that.
Could represent some
advection diffusion problem
in some bounded domain.
Could be a PDE.
It could just be an ordinary
differential equation, right,
but a boundary value problem.
And with this class
of relaxation methods,
we try not to exactly
satisfy this equation.
We relax that assumption.
We try to somehow
discretize this function.
It could be temperature,
could be energy,
could be velocity or momentum.
It could be lots of
different things.
Try to relax the constraint that
this is satisfied everywhere.
And we try to satisfy in some
approximate sense instead.
So we discussed
collocation methods,
where we take the domain
we're interested in
and we divide it up
into a series of points.
And we try to satisfy this
equation at those points.
And we have some approximation
for the function,
its representation
at those points.
That approximation could
be a finite difference
approximation.
That approximation could
be a basis set expansion.
It could be a finite
volume approximation.
We could expand in terms
of local basis functions.
That's the finite
element method.
We covered all these
different methods.
That involves
chopping the domain up
into a series of
points and trying
to satisfy the function
at each of those points.
There was an alternative method,
this sort of Galerkin method,
where instead of trying to
satisfy the function at each
of those points, we have
some basis set expansion.
So we have some
approximate representation
of our function in terms
of these basis sets--
in terms of this basis set.
And instead, we try
to make it be the case
that the integral
of our operator
applied to our approximation--
I'm going to break chalk--
multiplied by each of
the basis functions
and then integrated over this
entire domain is equal to 0.
So we try to satisfy this
equation with respect
to each of these basis
functions, essentially, right?
There's some-- this isn't
going to exactly satisfy
the equation.
This is an approximation.
It's not going to exactly
satisfy the boundary value
problem we were after.
But the projection
of the residual,
or how far off we are
with this operator,
on each of the basis
functions, we're
going to try to force to be 0.
So rather than trying to
get a pointwise solution
of the problem, we're going
to try to sort of smooth out
the error with respect
to the basis functions
and make this
equation is satisfied
as it possibly can with respect
to these basis functions.
And that's the Galerkin view.
So it's different.
It's like you're
trying to minimize
sort of a global error with
respect to the basis functions,
as opposed to a
pointwise error, OK?
And again, these basis
functions can be chosen
in a lot of different ways.
They can be chosen as
sort of global functions.
They can be things
like sines and cosines.
We may know that the
solution to this equation
looks a lot like sines and
cosines, so that makes sense.
Or we may choose local
basis functions instead,
little tent functions in 1D.
They're actually tent functions
in many dimensions as well.
You can imagine sort of
extending that to look
like a tent in many dimensions.
That's the finite
element method.
So we can choose those basis
functions however we want.
And the goal is to just minimize
this residual with respect
to each of the basis
functions that we include
in our approximate solution.
And we would call that a
reasonable approximation.
Presumably, as the
number of basis functions
goes to infinity, this
is going to converge.
That's the applied
mathematician's job,
to show us that it's going to
converge to the true solution
of the equations.
OK?
So those are the
methods that we--
those are the methods
that we apply.
Good choices of basis
function are important.
So there was this discussion
about quantum chemistry,
where you're trying to
solve the Schrodinger
equation for n electrons,
there's 3n degrees of freedom.
So a very
high-dimensional space.
How are you going to do that?
You do it with basis
set expansions.
And the choice of those basis
functions is really important.
So if you read a
quantum chemistry paper,
you'll see they give a long
series of digits and numbers
that are meant to indicate which
basis set expansion they used.
And for certain
classes of problem,
some are better than others.
And they make the
problem actually
solvable when it's not, if you
were to just choose your basis
functions without care for
the physics of the problem.
Sam.
AUDIENCE: The last homework,
in the Galerkin method,
where you multiplied
by the complex,
how did you get one basis
set, basis functions?
Where does that fit into this?
JAMES SWAN: Well, it should
have been right here.
So technically,
the basis functions
don't have to be
real-valued functions.
They can be
complex-valued functions.
And then this is, in some
sense, a dot product,
an inner product in the space
of these basic functions.
And the proper form
for an inner product
when we have
complex-valued things
is to take the real part
of one and multiply it
with the complex
part of another.
So that should have
been right here.
This should be the
complex conjugate.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when we
do the Galerkin method,
we necessarily have to
approximate these derivatives
and things using
basis functions.
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But in the
collocation method,
there was lots of other
ways that we could do it,
like find differences.
I know you mentioned
a few of them earlier.
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAMES SWAN: That's right.
AUDIENCE: That [? LOT term ?]
kind of contains also
the basis function in
the Galerkin method,
or in the collocation method.
JAMES SWAN: Well,
in the-- if we have
an expansion of the
sort of objective
that we're trying to calculate
in terms of those basis
functions, L is
the real L, right?
It is what it is.
This is the model
equation to be solved.
We operate on our approximate
solution with the real L.
In the collocation method,
it may be the real L,
or it may be some
approximation for L.
If we do finite differences,
we're approximating
all these derivatives.
If we do a basis
set expansion and we
try to satisfy that at a
certain number of points,
we're not approximating L.
We're approximating T instead.
So they're a little
bit different.
More questions?
So that's BVPs.
This picture applies
for PDEs, too.
So this is the integral
over the domain
of interest, the domain
that's bounded by our boundary
conditions.
These basis functions don't
have to be in one dimension.
They can be in any number
of dimensions we want.
We just want them to be good
basis functions in principle.
So for finite elements,
you use little tents.
They're multi-dimensional
tents, but they're still tents.
The same as these hat
functions that Professor Green
talked about in 1D.
Just do them in many dimensions.
They work exactly the same way.
They're easy to take
the derivatives of.
These intervals are, for the
most part, simple to calculate.
And that's why COMSOL, for
example, uses that methodology.
It's based on this sort
of Galerkin picture.
So PDEs, BVPs look very similar.
Usually, when we're talking
about spatial dimensions,
they look very similar.
When we go to the
time domain, things
get a little more confusing.
That mixes together what we
know from ODE IVPs with what
we know from boundary
value problems now.
So you talked about
the method of lines
last time as one
way of studying,
for example, parabolic partial
differential equations.
You have the spatial
discretization like this.
And then in time, you have
some ODE IVP technique
that you integrate forward.
You rely on these
robust ODE methods that
know how to control
the numerical error,
can detect, maybe, when there's
some sort of an instability
and try to damp it out by
altering the time step so
that things stay stable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I can't
visualize the local basis.
Can you give me an [INAUDIBLE]
expression for the local basis?
JAMES SWAN: Sure.
So first of all, there are a
lot of local basis functions
we could write down, OK?
AUDIENCE: This is
just one of them.
JAMES SWAN: There
are many of them.
So yes, let's do the hat.
OK?
Let's suppose I
have this line in x,
and I target in my
collocation method
a series of points, column
x i minus 1, xi, x i plus 1,
and they extend
well beyond here.
It doesn't matter
where they are.
I choose where they are based
on the physics of the problem.
I'll put them where
I want them to go.
And in fact, you might even
try to optimize where they go.
So you might start with
some distribution of them,
and then move them
around in some way
to improve the quality
of your solution, right?
Maybe you distribute
them uniformly at first,
and then you notice, oh,
my solution is changing
very quickly over here.
I would like more
points in this region.
In MATLAB, there's
a function called
bvp4c, which is a boundary
value problem solver.
It solves 1D boundary
value problems.
And it does precisely this.
It uses finite differences
and collocation.
And the good thing
about it is it's
trying to adaptively
change where
these points are positioned.
So it solves it, it looks where
things are changing quickly,
and tries to shift its points
around and resolve it in order
to improve the quality
of the solution,
hit certain targets
for the error.
So what are these-- what
would these local basis
functions look like?
So we talked about these hats.
They're 1 here.
They're going to be 0 on
either side of this point.
We could call this our hat i,
which is centered at point xi.
And it's going to be a
piecewise sort of function.
It's going to be an increasing
linear function between x i
minus 1 and xi.
So for x between xi and x i
minus 1, it'll have one form.
Then it's going to switch.
It's going to be a decreasing
function on the other side.
So between xi and x i plus 1,
it'll have a different form.
So here, it's going to
increase between 0 and 1.
So it's going to have
to look something
like x minus x i minus 1
divided by xi minus x i minus 1.
So it goes from 0 to 1.
And then on the other
side, it's going
to have to have
the opposite sign.
So this is going to
have to look like--
let's see, x minus x i plus 1
divided by xi minus x i plus 1.
Will that do it?
I think so.
OK?
You want me to make
it look like this one.
So we could have plus 1 xi,
and then put a minus sign
in front of it if you want.
You decide how you
want to write it.
But it describes this line
here and this line here.
But there are other choices.
So it doesn't have to be
piecewise linear necessarily.
A lot of times, people
choose different types
of splines, different types
of interpolating functions.
They might not be
localized to one point.
They might be localized
over a few points.
Maybe something about the
physics of a particular problem
that tell you,
you can't get away
with these piecewise
linear functions.
They're not good
enough to describe,
say, higher-order
derivatives in your equation.
So you might instead
interpolate with, I don't know,
like a quadratic basis function
that spans a few more points.
That'd be fine.
It would be easy to do the
integration in your Galerkin
method.
You just do these integrals out.
They're complicated, but you do
them once for a generic point
xi, and you know their value
for every point in the domain.
So you choose them.
You choose the basis set.
But that'll give me an equation
for the tent function centered
at xi.
That's the tent function
centered at any point
in the domain, in principle.
In many dimensions, right--
so if I have two dimensions,
you see in COMSOL, you have
a sort of a triangular mesh.
And what does my
tent function do?
It sort of stands up, stands
up above the triangle.
It's a real tent now.
It's coming out of the board.
Can you see it?
Put on your 3D glasses.
You'll see it.
But it's coming
out of the board.
It has height 1 above
this triangular domain.
It sits at the center of
the triangle, for example.
It's one way to
draw these elements.
There are actually many
ways to draw these elements.
This is just one way of
drawing these elements.
OK?
Good.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Could you
please explain why central
differencing is second-order
accurate and not--
JAMES SWAN: Oh, good question.
Good question.
So why is central differencing
second-order accurate?
So the central
difference formula
says that the derivative
of a function x
could be written as--
let's see, f at x i plus
1 minus f at x i minus 1,
divided by 2 delta x.
Or let's say these aren't
equally spaced points.
Well, let's make these
equally spaced points for now.
Let's make it easy.
So let's say x i plus
delta x and x i minus--
it'll make our lives easier
if we do it this way.
It can be generalized, but let's
do it the easiest possible way.
And this is the derivative
at the point xi.
Graphically, here's
x, here's xi.
Here's my function.
I want to know what
the slope here is.
And I'm going to approximate it
by looking one point upstream
and one point downstream.
And I'm going to connect
those points with a line.
You would agree that
as the spacing gets
smaller and smaller, it will be
a good approximation for what
the derivative is.
So why is it
second-order accurate?
So you can show that.
It's not too hard.
You can show that using
Taylor series expansion.
Like everything
else in this course,
the Taylor series
is really a key.
So let's look at it.
So f at x i plus delta x.
I want to write this
as a Taylor series
expansion about the point xi.
So tell me the first term.
f of xi.
OK, tell me the second term.
AUDIENCE: f prime at xi.
JAMES SWAN: f prime at xi.
Times?
AUDIENCE: Delta x.
JAMES SWAN: Delta x.
Tell me the third term.
AUDIENCE: 1/2 f double prime.
JAMES SWAN: 1/2 f
double prime at?
AUDIENCE: Xi.
JAMES SWAN: Times?
AUDIENCE: Delta x squared.
JAMES SWAN: How big
is the third term?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWAN: OK.
Is this always true, by the way?
This?
Not always, right?
There are lots of functions,
non-analytic functions that
don't have these
sorts of expansions.
So we're sort of--
we've got to have a function
that has these derivatives.
They need to exist
at the point xi.
Let's assume that's true, OK?
Good.
OK, now I'm going to do
something really simple.
Let's write f at
x i minus delta x.
And let's just point
out the differences
between these two formulas.
So this is the same.
This switches sign because
delta x switched signs.
It was plus delta x.
Now it's minus delta x.
This is the same, delta x
squared, same as minus delta
x squared.
Doesn't matter.
This one down here-- well, OK.
It's order delta x cubed.
It'll actually look the same
but have the opposite sign.
OK?
We can't resolve it, though.
That's sort of the
tricky part, right?
We don't know.
We don't know for sure
what value that takes on.
This just gives us
a bound for how big
the error is in this expansion.
So let's now compute
what's in that formula.
So if you take the difference
between this and this,
these two will cancel.
These two will combine.
I'll get 2 f prime
xi times delta x.
These two will cancel.
So I'll get 0.
These two, I can't rely
on them necessarily
canceling each other out.
In fact, they want to
combine in principle, right?
We've just bounded the error.
Here, we don't really
know what it is,
but it gives me something that's
order delta x cubed in size.
So this is the--
this is 1 minus 2.
It's 2 f prime xi times
delta x plus the error,
which is order delta x cubed.
If I divide by 2 delta x--
I know you guys hate it when
the instructor does this,
but you know, you can't help it.
Divide by delta x, the error
becomes order delta x squared.
So if the derivative is this
thing plus some order delta
x squared piece, it's
second-order accurate,
we would say, right?
The error is going to be reduced
like the square of the spacing.
Now you can imagine all the
finite difference formulas out
there in the world are
constructed in this way.
You use Taylor series expansion.
You've got as many
terms as you need
to go for the level
of accuracy you're
trying to achieve for different
points based in different ways.
And you try to dream up
some linear combination
of these things so that you get
a certain level of accuracy.
They're also not unique.
I can construct these in
a lot of different ways
and have the same sort
of error level out here,
but different coefficients
associated with the error,
but the same overall scaling.
And then you might choose
different approximations
for other reasons.
Sam.
AUDIENCE: What would
stop me from going
on further and then
just subtracting
f prime from both sides?
I mean, it wouldn't
really tell me anything,
except maybe the order of
[INAUDIBLE] approximately 0.
JAMES SWAN: Well, I mean, yeah.
So let's say you go out further.
What's the next term here?
It's going to be 1 over 6 f
triple prime xi delta x cubed.
And here, you'll have minus that
because I cubed the delta x.
So when I combine
them, I'll actually
get 1 over 3 f triple prime.
So I could do a little better.
If I knew what my
function was, I
can tell you exactly
how big the error was.
I can tell you
that it was as big
as the third derivative of f.
My function doesn't have a
third derivative at that point.
The error might be huge.
And it's possible to
construct functions that lack
that particular property, OK?
So you can go further, and you
can use it to sort of quantify
exactly how many you
think the error might
be in the approximation.
But it's all constructed
from linear combinations
of different Taylor expansions
about nearby points.
And the related
problem, actually,
the equivalent problem is
polynomial interpolation.
So the sort of--
if you can somehow, in your
mind, transpose this problem,
it looks a lot like
polynomial interpolation.
So these two are intimately
related to each other.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How much
do we have to know
about polynomial interpolation?
JAMES SWAN: How much
do you have to know
about polynomial interpolation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like, do we
have to be able to compute
the primes and polynomials?
JAMES SWAN: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: Do we have
to be able to compute
the primes of polynomials?
[INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: What do I
want to say about that?
I wouldn't expect
that level of detail.
I think it's quite
difficult to construct
Lagrange polynomial
expansions by hand.
I don't know anyone
who does that
professionally or for pleasure.
I think that's a bad idea.
You should understand
polynomial interpolation.
the context
in which it's important.
What is polynomial interpolation
important for, numerically?
Do you recall?
Hersch.
AUDIENCE: Numerical integration.
JAMES SWAN: Numerical
integration, right.
So this was really the key
to numerical integration,
was trying to construct
appropriate approximations
of our function from
a finite set of data
and figure out the
area under the curve.
So you should understand how one
uses polynomial interpolation
to do numerical integration.
But I wouldn't expect us to
ask you to actually compute
a polynomial interpolant
and numerically
integrate it by hand.
I think that's too much.
OK?
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
More questions.
Hersch.
AUDIENCE: Now do
you mind showing
how the trapezoid rule is
over delta t squared accurate?
JAMES SWAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: For ODE IVPs.
JAMES SWAN: For ODE--
AUDIENCE: IVPs.
JAMES SWAN: ODE IVP, OK.
OK, so we have to have
an ODE we want to solve.
Can I just do-- can I do
a one-dimensional unknown?
Do I need to do a vector here?
Can I just-- would
you be satisfied
if I wrote this as f of
y and t and that it's
sufficiently general?
That way, you don't
have to blame me
when I forget to underscore
things along the way.
And we don't have to
think about the Jacobian
or anything like that.
OK.
So oh, time derivative, right?
So there's the ODE
we're going to solve.
The trapezoid rule.
OK, so let's do this
the following way.
It's actually going to wind up
looking very similar to what
we just did, which is useful.
I might even be able to pull
that board down and reuse it
at a certain point.
So that'll be good.
Let's do this.
So what is-- ultimately,
what is ODE IVP solving like?
What are you trying to do when
you solve one of these things?
AUDIENCE: Extrapolate.
JAMES SWAN: It's
extrapolation, right?
I know the value of y initially.
I'm trying to figure out where
the hell this thing is going.
I've got to extrapolate for it.
And you should be very
uncomfortable with the notion
that I can do that, right?
How good a job can I do
predicting the future
knowing how things are now?
It's really quite complicated.
In fact, it's so
complicated, there
are certain circumstances in
which it's not really possible.
Discovered here
at MIT, actually.
So there was weather
research going
on at a certain point at MIT.
It's a very famous case.
A researcher, a very
famous researcher
was doing numerical simulations
of a weather model in an ODE
IVP.
He ran it for a
while, and he stopped.
He looked at his end
state, the last value of y
in his simulation.
He put in three digits, used
that as the initial condition,
and started his simulation
again, and it went wacky.
Didn't look anything like
the initial solution.
OK?
How did that happen?
It seemed fine up to that point.
Solution's cranking along.
He stopped.
He took three digits
accuracy out of the computer,
and he started again.
And it, I don't know,
did something else.
So there are problems that are
inherently chaotic and very
sensitive to their
initial conditions.
They're hard to resolve.
So the entire point of
doing this sort of analysis
of ODE IVPs is, at least
in the best-case scenarios,
we want to try to manage
the error associated
with these kinds
of extrapolation.
In some case, it's
really not very possible.
You don't know the
initial conditions
well enough to predict
what the final state is.
So there are problems
that are inherently
unstable or sensitive to
their initial conditions.
They don't have
to blow up either.
They can find themselves
moving through the phase space
in some way that's
very, very sensitive.
And two points that
start very close
together can wind up very
far apart from each other.
So that's deterministic chaos.
But outside of those problems,
we try to do this extrapolation
and figure out sort of a
best approximation for where
we think our target
function is going.
So what are we trying to do?
In principle, we know
y at a certain point.
And we want to know
where it's going to go.
And so you might say, well,
maybe I know dy dt initially.
And so I should just
move a small increment
along that slope.
And that's a good approximation.
That's the forward
Euler approximation.
Trapezoid rule--
or equivalently,
the midpoint rule--
says, well, maybe
that initial slope
isn't really the
right one to use.
Maybe y does
something like this,
and we should actually
look sort of halfway
between the point we're
trying to extrapolate
to and the current point, and
use that value as the best
approximation of the
derivative and extrapolate
for it along that.
And it turns out
that's more accurate.
So what does that look like?
So one typically
says, you know, y
i plus 1 is equal to yi
plus delta t times f y
i plus 1/2 comma.
And we won't worry
about the t here,
but it's going to have
to be t i plus 1/2.
So I look halfway
forward in time.
And I say, that's the slope,
that's the derivative of y.
So let me step forward
along that line.
It turns out this is going to
be reasonably accurate if I
can get a good approximation
for y i plus 1/2.
OK?
OK.
So let's-- [COUGH].
Excuse me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this the
midpoint method or--
JAMES SWAN: They're functionally
equivalent to each other.
They work in precisely
the same fashion.
So whether it's the trapezoidal
rule or the midpoint method,
they have fundamentally
the same pictures there.
OK?
Here, if you do
forward Euler, you're
doing numerical integration,
assuming the slope is
the value at this point.
If you're doing the midpoint
method or the trapezoid rule,
you're trying to get a better
approximation for the slope,
right?
So you're trying to
build a trapezoid
and integrate the area
under that trapezoid.
So they're fundamentally
the same thing.
Now the question becomes, I
don't know f at y i plus 2.
So I need to use a Taylor
expansion of this quantity
in terms of the value
of f that I know.
So I need to expand this
in terms of f at yi.
And I'll know the derivative
of y with respect to t at yi.
I know it from this formula.
So if I take this
Taylor expansion
and I carry it out to the
first term I don't know,
which is the order
delta t squared term,
and I carry through
all of the errors,
I'll find out that there's a
numerical error proportional
to order delta t squared.
So I need to do exactly
this and substitute
in terms of quantities I know
and quantities I don't know.
And the leading-order
contribution
of the quantities I don't know
will give me this order delta
t squared piece.
And that'll give me
the local truncation
error in the solution.
Does that make sense?
So it's still Taylor expansions.
Good.
Other questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why is the central
difference 0, not [INAUDIBLE]??
JAMES SWAN: Why is the
central difference--
AUDIENCE: No, why's the
outlook [INAUDIBLE] the one
we did [INAUDIBLE]?
That one is not implicit, right?
JAMES SWAN: I don't think
I said anything like that.
So implicit versus
explicit really
depends on what
you're trying to do.
So if I'm trying to use
a central difference
formula of some sort to solve
an ODE which progresses forward
in time--
it has a direction associated
with it that things always
progress in-- then this
might be an explicit formula.
Because I could solve for f at
x i plus 1 in terms of what's
going on in the past.
If we tried to do finite
differences in a boundary value
problem instead, and that
boundary value problem
doesn't have some direction
associated with it anymore--
so it's not like space has
some preferred direction.
Time goes in a
preferred direction.
Space does not.
You may find that the pointwise
equations you write down cannot
be solved strictly in
terms of one of these.
You can't just move this to
the other side of the equation
and solve in terms
of everything else.
So you'll have a
coupled set of equations
that can't be diagonalized,
can't be simply reduced.
They won't have the form
of, say, of triangular
matrix, for example.
This will happen.
And in that case, you would
say this formula is implicit.
So it really depends on which
problem you're trying to solve,
whether you label them
explicit or implicit.
Explicit is going to
mean that the data I want
can be found with
a simple equation
solve in terms of
the data I know.
Implicit is going
to mean I've got
to do some complicated
equation-solving methodology.
I've got to go do
Gaussian elimination,
or I need to go to fsolve
and solve this thing.
The data that I want
is not available
through some simple scheme where
I can just write explicitly
a thing I want equals some
function of things I know.
OK?
Other questions.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],, how
many questions will there be?
And for each question,
how many subquestions?
Could you just roughly--
JAMES SWAN: Oh, man.
The question was,
how many questions
and how many
subquestions on the quiz?
Yeah.
The quiz is-- in
my opinion, it's
now shorter than the
last one that you took.
We've been pretty
sensitive to time concerns.
We know that was
something that was
an issue on the previous quiz.
I think there's only going
to be two problems on it.
They have many parts,
but we've really
tried to refine the
questions in those parts.
That's what you should expect.
It's comprehensive.
It Covers all the things
from this section.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Also, DAEs problem--
JAMES SWAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It says that
as index increases,
we have less degrees of freedom.
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you explain?
JAMES SWAN: Sure.
Sure.
So higher-index DAEs
come up all the time.
And the degrees
of freedom refers
to your ability to
choose initial conditions
for the problem.
And we saw several
examples in which,
if we tried to convert
that DAE to an ODE,
we found along the way that
there were certain hidden
conditions that all the
initial conditions would need
to satisfy in order for
this ODE, the system of ODEs
that we built from the DAEs, to
follow the same solution path
or solution manifold as the
original DAE system would
follow.
The higher the
index is, the more
of these hidden
constraints you find.
And those hidden
constraints tell you
that the initial conditions
have to be very particular.
So there are--
I would encourage you to
look at the specific examples
in the notes.
And you'll see there
was a simple CSTR
example that was index 1
and almost unconstrained,
basically.
There was an index
2 DAE in which
the consistent initial
conditions, you actually
couldn't specify any of
the initial conditions.
They were fixed by the
equations themselves.
But remember, that sort of
happened because certain DAEs
are pathological in nature.
They often ask us to do
something we can't do
physically, like try to
control the input by-- or try
to predict--
let's see, how do I say this?
It's easy for us to predict
the output knowing the input.
It's very hard for us to predict
the input knowing the output.
And these higher-index
DAEs were essentially
asking us to do that.
There's a lag in how
we measure things.
And it's easier to go
forward through a process
than backwards through a process
and make these predictions.
There's inherent sensitivity
in doing the former.
It's the same sort
of sensitivity
you get from these
systems of ODEs, in fact.
A small change in the
initial conditions
can lead to big
changes in the outlet.
So if I measure the outlet,
it's hard to predict the inlet.
It's just very inherently
difficult to do.
And so formulating a model
which has this high index,
you will naturally
find that your choice
of initial conditions for
the solution of that model
are constrained.
And they're constrained
because of the way
you formulated the model.
If you're actually trying to do
control of a chemical process,
it's going to be very difficult
to try to somehow control the--
try to make the input be a
certain thing by controlling
the output.
That doesn't make
sense almost, right?
It seems very, very strange.
You would really want to
change the input in order
to hit a target in the output.
How do you change the output
and hit a target in the input?
The process doesn't actually
care about things in that way.
And you saw that.
Because in that
particular CSTR example,
you couldn't fix any of
the initial conditions,
actually, right?
There was no free
choice in the problem.
Everything was
automatically fixed,
and you had to have perfect
knowledge of everything
in the system.
I wasn't actually able
to do control in a sense
there, right?
I could just measure
the output, and I
can tell you what the
input was supposed to be.
And it was super sensitive
to my measurement.
So these high-index
problems tend
to come up when we want
to constrain things
in a way that's, let's say,
physically quite challenging.
High-index problems
are incredibly
common in mechanical
engineering, things
like robotics where
you want to make
sure the robot's arm doesn't
whack someone in the head.
This is important.
And so you're
trying to constrain
all these degrees of
freedom and the paths
that it's going to move on.
And all those constraints--
I mean, there's actually a
very narrow envelope in which
this thing gets to operate.
So accurately
simulating the motion
and then making the robot move
that way is very empowering.
In chemical processes,
that's true, too.
But oftentimes, we can make
choices in model formulation,
right?
Like how you try to
control the process that
can ease those constraints.
If I had some control
or it doesn't control
in an instantaneous
fashion, even
if it's a very
high-bandwidth control,
there's still a finite time
for signals to propagate.
There's dynamics associated
with the controller that
can convert that DAE system into
a system of ODEs, for example.
You don't have-- they
may be stiff ODEs.
DAEs are the limit of sort of
infinite stiffness in ODEs.
But they may not be as
troublesome to solve
as the DAE system would be.
OK?
It's about model formulation.
OK, can I talk
briefly about PDEs?
Is that OK?
I'll tell you a
little bit about it.
I like this finite
volume method.
I think it's very interesting.
You've got some notes on it.
I think I like it
because I think
it comes very
naturally, actually,
to chemical engineers.
Because the problems we like
to solve are of the type
that finite volume
eats for breakfast.
These are problems
of conservation.
So we have a
conserved quantity b.
Is that what Dean
uses in his book?
The new version still uses b as
the conserved quantity, right?
So the time rate
of change of b is
equal to minus the gradient
in the flux plus some,
I don't know, some
volumetric change.
Maybe a reaction, maybe
there's some injections
somewhere of mass or momentum,
or you know, some source.
And our numerical
solution, oftentimes, we
would like it to also
conserve b, right?
Conserve mass, conserve
momentum, conserve energy,
conserve species.
These collocation
methods in general,
or relaxation methods in
general, don't do that.
They're not designed to do that.
You might be able to construct,
for example, basis functions
that have that property that
they will satisfy conservation.
You might be able to construct
certain meshing methods,
certain collocation methods--
and this is one of them,
the finite volume method--
that respects conservation.
And here's how you do it.
So you worked really
hard in transport
to derive these differential
forms of the transport
equations.
But finite volume actually
likes the integral form.
So you've got to go back.
So you've got to take the
integral of these equations
over some volume V. And
then the time derivative
of the amount of
b in this volume
is related to the flux
of b through the surfaces
of that volume plus the
amount of generation
or consumption of the conserved
quantity within that volume V,
right?
And this volume is
my finite volume.
I take the domain of
interest, and I chop it
up into all these
little volumes.
And then I just need to
conserve b within that volume.
So I have the first
equation you learned
in chemical engineering, right?
The amount of accumulation
of the conserved quantity
is related to the fluxes in
and out of the control volume
plus the amount of
generation or consumption
within the control volume.
This comes very naturally
to chemical engineers.
It fits perfectly in the
problems we like to solve.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the nominal vector
pointing outwards or inwards?
JAMES SWAN: Well, it all
depends on how we choose
to write j, actually, right?
So is j the flux into
or out of this volume?
So I won't prescribe that here.
It depends on what
you chose as the flux.
So maybe, I don't
know, what does--
Dean writes the stress tensor
with the opposite sign of Bird,
Stewart, and Lightfoot.
So these guys, that's the
flux of momentum, right?
They choose a sign.
Then the normals have
to respect that sign.
Doesn't really matter.
The physics doesn't care.
You just have to choose the
flux in the right direction.
If we think of j as the
flux into the volume,
n should point in.
OK, so you have this
conservation equation.
You've got to solve for
each of your finite volumes.
And the finite volumes
are coupled together,
because a flux out of one volume
is a flux into another volume,
right?
So you can think of these
volumes as being little CSTRs.
They're all sitting
next to each other.
And they're all linked together
by these volumetric flows
from one to another.
And that's, in
fact, what they are.
The key is, how do I model
these fluxes, basically?
The accuracy of
the method is going
to be set by how big a
volume am I going to model.
Can't have infinitely
small volumes.
There are going to
be too many of them
in my domain to solve
the problem accurately.
And then, do I have good
models for these fluxes?
And you can think about
these terms in this way.
That sometimes is useful.
So this big B, the amount
of b in the volume,
is like the volume
times the density
of b, the volumetric
density of b in the volume.
The average density
in the volume.
R is like the volume
multiplied by the average rate
of generation or consumption.
F is the flux in or out.
It's the sum over all the
faces of the flux through each
of the faces, which is the
area of the face multiplied
by the average flux
through the face.
So this is the
normal to the face,
and this is the flux
through the face.
And so I just--
I'm going to solve
this equation.
I try to figure out, in each
volume, what's the average b?
That's what this tells me.
On average, what is b?
On average, what is
the concentration?
the amount of momentum?
On average, what is
the total energy?
That's fine.
So finite volume, very simple.
What's nice about it?
Well, you know, it's
really suitable to any sort
of geometry you want to look at.
We want to solve this equation,
say, in this square domain.
We divide the domain up into a
bunch of little square volumes.
And in each volume, we just make
sure that the amount of this b
balances the fluxes
coming through the volume
and the amount of
consumption or generation
of that quantity
within the volume.
But it didn't have to be
a square domain, right?
A square domain, that's OK.
But maybe I want to solve
it on some circular domain.
Well, I can divide that
up into volumes, too.
And actually, these
equations are the same.
They look identical.
I've just got to calculate the
flux through each of the faces.
OK?
But maybe I'm interested
in, I don't know,
pollution in one
of the Great Lakes.
And I want to know how
concentration of some pollutant
is transformed.
I'd divide this up into a
bunch of little volumes, too.
And now I've got to
calculate the flux
through each of these faces.
And that links all
these domains together.
Maybe I'm interested
in transport
within some porous
medium-- say, a bone.
I think it's someone's
hip joint here.
OK, well, I divide that up
into a bunch of volumes.
And I still solve the exact
same conservation equation.
So I've sort of decoupled
the problem of meshing
and equations, the governing
equations associated
with the meshes.
As long as I have a way
to divide the domain up.
It may be very complicated.
I'm going to go ask a buddy
in applied math to do that.
But I'm going to come to him
with the right engineering
equations for each of those
domains, a little equation
for a CSTR.
OK?
Turns out this-- you know,
one of the most common
fluid mechanical codes out
there that people use now
is OpenFOAM.
So it's very common.
Lots of people use it.
It's a very general solver.
Does finite volume.
That's the method
it chooses to use.
Why does it choose to use it?
Because it wants to
conserved momentum?
A guaranteed momentum
conservation.
Can't lose momentum,
can't lose energy.
Can't lose mass.
I just have to pass
the right amount
between each of these faces.
As long as my calculation
of that is accurate,
I've conserved the quantity.
Never evaporates.
Finite difference, finite
element, different basis
set expansions-- they
will have this problem
that at low levels
of accuracy, you
can have sort of artificial
consumption of, say,
the quantity, or
artificial production
of the conserved
quantity of interest.
So this can be a very nice
way to solve these problems.
It's another relaxation method.
It's a type of collocation.
I divide the domain up.
And then I try to satisfy
conservation equations on each
of these little volumes.
Hence finite volume.
OK?
OK.
So how do you solve PDEs by
hand or write your own code?
There's a nice
little tutorial here.
We'll see how far we're able to
get through it before I've got
to give you guys your cards.
But I'll illustrate
some key points
that I think are
really important.
So step one, no
matter what method
you choose, whether you choose
collocation, whether you choose
Galerkin, whether
you're using basis sets
or you're using finite
elements or finite volumes,
you've got some domain you're
trying to solve your PDE in.
And you've got to discretize it.
You've got to figure out
how to decompose the domain.
So for finite differences,
you might decompose it
into a series of
nodes at which you
want to know the value of
your function, whatever
that function is.
For finite volume,
you would decompose it
into cells in which
you would like
to know the average value
of your conserved quantity.
For finite elements, you divide
the domain up into some points,
across which local basis
functions span the region.
We would like to know the
weighting of these local basis
functions near each
of these points.
But you've got to
divide the domain up.
And the most important
thing is you always
choose the spacing of the nodes,
or the dimensions of the cells,
to match the physics.
A very natural thing to
want to do is to pick--
say I've got this square grid--
to pick the number of grid
points to discretize with.
I say, I'm going
to use 100 points
in this dimension and 100
points in that dimension.
Actually, that tells me nothing.
That's an irrelevant number.
The physics has no idea how many
grid nodes you put in there.
Doesn't care.
There are length scales that are
intrinsic to the problem you're
trying to study.
And the discretization should
resolve those physically
relevant length scales.
So it might be the
case that I only
need a resolution of one part
in 10 along this dimension
and one part in 10
along this dimension
because the physics
are such that that's
good to get a description of
the solution to this problem.
It might be that I need one part
in a million in this dimension
and one part in 10
in that dimension
because the physics
are that way.
So you really want to
think about length scales,
not numbers of nodes.
It's a very common mistake.
You say, well, 100 and 100,
that makes sense, or 10 and 10.
Or you know, you
pick these randomly.
But you want to think
about physics instead.
Here's a good example.
This is my fault. You'll
solve a problem like this.
You already saw it in some
sense in the finite element
or COMSOL tutorial.
But there's a little drug
patch here near this red zone.
It's leaking drug
into a sheer flow,
and it's all being
advected down.
Here's my solution
to the problem.
I think it's a pretty good one.
Here's a solution from when I
taught of course two years ago
that the TAs produced.
And I didn't talk with the TAs
about this issue with length
scales.
And it sort of got
the right structure.
You can see, here's
the patch, and there's
some advection and diffusion.
But it's not a very stable
solution, it turns out.
It's also not very accurate.
It doesn't reflect
the essential physics.
And the point is
actually the scales.
So here, the patch was 1
centimeter in diameter.
And so here, you
got many centimeters
long this direction,
where you get advection.
Here, you've got 2
centimeters in this direction.
But actually, the solution
is really confined down
to this small space.
The physics all happens at
fractions of a centimeter.
You took Transport,
so you know that this
is a problem in which
there's a boundary layer.
And all the change
in concentration
is confined to that
little boundary layer.
So really, when you do
your numerical solution,
you'll do like was done up here.
Now the lengths are made
dimensionless on the width
of the patch, but
they're-- you know,
you can think of these as
measured in centimeters.
But look at the dimension here.
We need to resolve
the solution down
at the 0.1 centimeter
and smaller scale.
I want to put all my little
discretization or my nodes
down here so that I can see how
the concentration field changes
as a function of distance.
I have to know something
about the physics
to do that, though, OK?
Can't just solve this blindly.
It may or may not be
the case that COMSOL
recognizes the
physical situation
and remeshes your problem
to put mesh points down
where they matter.
It may do that.
It may not do that.
It just doesn't know.
People build heuristics to
try to solve these remeshing
problems, but they
may not always apply.
So it's good to understand
the physics of the problem.
This drug patch problem, this
is a pretty common transport
problem.
I mean, did Professor
Bazant give you guys
a talk during your
visit weekend?
Was that this last year?
Was that two years ago?
It was two years ago.
He does problems with
bromine flow batteries.
And they worked
exactly this way.
You have flow of bromine in.
An electrochemical reaction
takes place at the surface.
This entire thing is
premised on the fact
that you have a
very thin boundary
layer in which the
electrochemical-- in which
the reagents are confined.
And if that boundary
layer gets too thick
and reaches the other electrode,
it screws up the reaction
and doesn't work as
a battery anymore.
So being able to resolve
concentration gradients
in this small domain, it's not
just important for this drug
problem.
It's important in general.
It's a common sort of
transport-y type problem.
And the numerical
solution is really
going to hinge on your ability
to recognize the physics
and resolve the solution
over the length scales that
are important in the problem.
OK?
So that's the number
one most important thing
for doing these PDEs.
The rest of the
notes will take you
through the construction
of a numerical solution
to the diffusion equation in
2D, and some different scenarios
that you might try to employ
in MATLAB to solve them,
and how you can accelerate the
solution using different MATLAB
functions.
It's fun to try
out and play with.
You'll see that I can make
the solution to this problem
go very fast for a domain
that's quite highly
discretized by recognizing
certain forms of the equations,
choosing certain
solvers to solve with.
OK?
Good.
All right, I'll meet
you guys in back,
and we'll hand out
these gift cards.
And good luck on your quiz.